okay so continuing on
with the kozushi okay and this time
we're going to go over the knee pull
so the knee pull
is going to work off his spinal
necessity for his posture okay it's
nothing but
a lever so if i try to pull
his uh line of gravity out of his face
support
from the bottom of the spine that's a
short lever
i won't have as good a mechanical
advantage
so i want to come near the top of the
spines and i'm doing that
so i'm coming towards the armpits and i
start to bring his line of gravity
up his body his center of gravity falls
outside his base support
and his balance becomes um
off balance okay so just working with
the knee pull
you'll do it from the side
and as you're doing just like all parts
of the closed guard
don't waste your groin muscles closing
this
off what is just key is that your hips
are on top and
in front of his hips okay so as i come
up i'm not squeezing any harder
just move
his line of gravity up his spine center
of gravity falls outside his face
and then we'll look at the four phases
of
getting up so we just did knees down
we'll do one leg up
and you'll do the same thing
same exercise just working on the knee
pull
then we'll pay attention to the second
step
so he goes one and as he starts to go
do it
one
okay let's go okay so of course if he
gets all the way up
and he drives his punch he's gonna have
way a lot of leverage so come down
but it's not so easy to get up he goes
it's not so easy okay so
it's not uncommon that after a few
attempts this is where he starts trying
to punch you
okay so we're gonna work from here
but the same kazushi pattern would apply
okay so as he goes to this punch
i feel his line of gravity coming out i
feed it
and i use his arm to take him
into that kazushi pattern
that we worked on last week so
he goes i'm stuck i keep it going
just turn it boom and you're up
a little clicker
[Music]
okay
okay so in this technique as he goes
back i'm not
this is not this is not gonna work okay
so as he as he goes to punch do you see
how i'm already affecting him
okay and so he's he's gonna correct he's
gonna throw his punch
and that's why that worked okay
so let's put a little energy into your
punches see i'm right there
[Music]
a little more energy
so let's say i lose contact oh hell yeah
cover up
but ideally he goes fast
stick stick to it follow the energy up
okay
so he goes a little quicker
you have intuition okay so he goes
and he's so light that i can go here
and just push him and get him
okay so he goes are you gonna punch
here we go there you go well
then this will work
he's stronger
and i cannot do the move embryonically i
can't go
balance and then you you're thinking
you're gonna do some scissor sweep or
something here
he's really strong i can't get it
so just like in touch he was that lucas
uh center of gravity never stops
traversing the map
so as he goes it's moving forward
you see it keeps going forward look
slowly
surely
so if he does this move
what i would call embryonically
mechanically
he'll never do it that's why they have
weight categories
okay because everyone does their moves
that way nowadays
so he goes boom
he's never gonna get me i'm gonna be
dynamic
and just move
or maybe i'm trained
and uh move to the side
and he's gonna push me stand up and i
know how to keep my posture my ground
vector where
he's never gonna get me so here we go
i actually have some internal skills
and he goes go
we're not going anywhere go try try
we're not going anywhere okay so he has
to keep
me moving so let's go slow stay
connected
here i come wait wait keep extension
wait let me throw myself
keep extension though okay and once you
feel
wait hold on i'm gonna talk to you start
to ride it
nope relax don't die your center though
start to ride it now the knee put push
up higher
don't see you're trying to throw me
sideways bring me up
up up up up now sideways there you go
let's do it again
follow it then everything moves back at
once
don't block me your whole body moves
here comes the knee push
that's it
okay let's go okay so he goes i'm
sticking to him
and this punch i'm i'm stuck to him
um i don't want it to come over where i
would do the
the overlook here okay so
same thing i go and i'm using the punch
to keep his line of gravity going
forward don't come off him
and don't let him come off of you so he
he's trying to come off of me
don't let him come off of you okay he
drops his elbow
don't let it come off of you keep your
ikey adhesion
so he goes long keep it
until it's no longer affecting his
balance
a little quicker
clicker
you